avant de se quitter ce soir
j'espère vous lycée avec quelques
questionnements
j'espère vous amener à questionner votre
votre place dans vos collectivités
j'espère à vous amener à vous
questionner sur votre vision du
leadership
puis peut-être même à vous questionner
sur tout ce que je vais vous dire en
fait si vous questionnez tout mission
accomplie
je vous dis ça pourquoi parce que je me
souviens que a mis 18 ans
la jeune fille de 18 ans que j'étais
avait un désir profond de
découvrir de se découvrir avait un
profond malaise certaine confusion même
je dirais avec sa propre personne avec
son rapport avec les autres aussi puis
certainement avait une idée pas du tout
clair sur la place qui devait occuper
dans sa collectivité
donc j'ai fait j'ai suivi la bonne
formule la formule qui m'a été
recommandé par mini école études
supérieures également partir voyager à
l'international aspirer un poste dans
une grande firme à l'international
pourquoi pas revenir pratiquer ma
profession en pensant que c'était la
formule gagnante
c'était une bonne formule je pense que
le constat est là je te nomme
indépendante ainsi subvenir à mes
besoins c'est ce que les parents
souhaitent au moins mais je voudrais que
le désavantage d'avoir suivi à la lettre
le protocole
c'est que ça m'a quand même pris
plus de 10 ans je vous dirai pour
arriver à un moment de confort pour
comprendre justement c'était quoi ma
place dans cette collectivité là je vois
y en a qui calcule bon 18 plus
je vous dise ah pourquoi parce que si je
peut vous éviter un aussi long trajet ça
sera déjà ça
la façon dont j'ai découverte ma place
dans ma collectivité c'est arrivé par
hasard
étrangement même je vous dirais je suis
tombé dans diversité
bon je lis l'on peut trouver je suis
tombé dans diverses cité
citer 1
je répète le même depuis tout à l'heure
collectivités villes communautés
en revenant de super beau monde à
l'international où tout le monde me
disait
good job
j'étais persuadé qu'en puisque j'avais
suivi la ligne directrice que je me
dirigeais vers vraiment quelque chose de
grandiose ça pas du tout été sans quand
je suis revenu je peux pas vous dire les
difficultés auxquelles j'ai été
affrontées pour trouver ma place
dans la diversité
ça a été une bonne chose parce que en
empruntant différents détours
dans l'une de ces cités dans lesquels je
me suis découverte j'ai surtout
redécouvert ma définition du leadership
à travers le travail des politiciens et
des politiciennes que j'ai observé
ce qui était particulièrement
intéressant au niveau local dans les
cités c'est que les politiciens sont
amenés à être ancrés dans leur milieu
ceux qui ne sont pas on le voit tout de
suite parce que les résultats sont pas
là en faisant ces découvertes sommes
amenés à totalement redéfinir la notion
du leadership et surtout de découvrir
que je vous disais plus tôt ma place
dans cette collectivité c'est ce que je
vous donne ce soir
l' avantage que vous avez selon moi
c'est qu'à partir du moment où vous
allez comprendre et redéfinir le
leadership
en ni liant votre place dans votre
collectivité vous allez pouvoir vraiment
avoir une définition qui vous est propre
moi celle que j'avais défini auparavant
elle était beaucoup plus liées à ce
qu'on peut les airs dans des livres à ce
qu'on peut entendre des conférences à ce
que l'on peut entendre dans des bons
podcast mais elle était grandement
teintées parce que ce que je voyais chez
les autres elle était nullement dit fini
par ma propre expérience par mon propre
vécu
et peu à peu j'ai découvert qui en étant
ancré dans ma cité dans ma collectivité
c'était l'une des meilleures façons de
puiser dans mes propres talents au
service des autres pour découvrir dans
quelle mesure j'étais capable de
peut-être refaire le monde
à mon avis
vous êtes dans une position vraiment
pris vie légis et ça je vous le dis là
en toute honnêteté je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi je me place ce soir
un peu comme
en position d'éclaireurs on va dire
génération y qui s'adresse à la
génération z pour lui dire
voici ce que j'ai vu
voici ce que je pense qu'ils sont viens
et je vous avertir vous êtes dans une
position exceptionnelle dans le cours de
l'histoire
pourquoi parce que vous pouvez compter
sur certaines personnes dans ma
génération
qui sont des leaders qui ont un pouvoir
d'influencé qui sont en mesure de
diriger le cours de certaines certains
des grands changements qui vont se
produire dans notre société
mais certains des leaders dans ma
génération
wii ont eu le courage de faire certaines
choses différemment mais doivent
composer avec des crèmes qui sont un peu
lié à ce que les générations précédentes
nous ont légué enzo ligue est plein de
bonnes choses les fondations des
fondations solides sur lesquelles on
peut construire aujourd'hui mais le hic
c'est que je remarque notamment que
dans ma position
il y a
comment je peux dire un gars de plus en
plus prononcées qui est en train de
s'accentuer entre vous et ceux qui nous
ont précédés
et ça c'est intéressant parce que ça
veut dire que les défis auxquels on fait
face aujourd'hui en tant que
collectivités deviennent de plus en plus
complexes semble de plus en plus
difficile à relever mais au contraire et
je le répète vous vous êtes dans une
position privilégiée pour provoquer un
changement extrêmement important exemple
parmi les différents défis dont on peut
parler aujourd'hui web 3.0 je vais pas
la première à en faire mention j'imagine
dans votre quotidien vous en empare du
merveilleux on n'est même plus dans le
web 2.0 mais ça qu'est ce que ça
implique dans votre quotidien vous avez
vous dira un avocat qui viennent nous
parler du web 3.0 oui je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que imaginez-vous que moi
même dans mon quotidien même en ma
pratique même lorsque je travaille que
ce soit en cabinet ou bien avec les
citoyens je peux voir les répercussions
certains mots qui habite notre société
si on parle du web 3.0 commentait ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut conjuguer ce
besoin de liberté d'expression par
exemple qui est enchâssé dans la charte
canadienne des droits et libertés
comment combiner tout ça avec ce besoin
d'expression qui contribue à l'art la
culture même avec certains enjeux qui
touchent par exemple à l'intimidation à
la haine au recrutement pour des
activités illégales
un autre type d'enjeux auxquels on peut
faire face aujourd'hui commentait ce
qu'on compose ce besoin d'assurer une
saine et bonne intelligente transition
écologique avec le fait qu' on n'est pas
encore tous d'accord sur la meilleure
façon d'assurer le développement et non
économique et l'innovation dans le
respect de l'environnement
il y a tellement d'enjeux complexes
il y en a qui sont primaires sont pas
justes d'équité de justice sociale
malgré tout nos avancées technologiques
on n'a pas encore été en mesure de
comprendre et de trouver les moyens
qui vont assurer briser les solitudes
tant chez les jeunes que chez les aînés
par exemple malgré toutes les avancées
technologiques on n'a pas nécessairement
encore trouvé les moyens d'assurer la
sécurité alimentaire pour tous et
surtout pour les moins nantis
on n'a pas encore trouvé la réponse
parfaite qui nous permettra ensemble
dans nos collectivités de s'assurer de
réparer les erreurs du passé
les erreurs qui certains malheureusement
pensent encore que à j-2 pointé du doigt
qu'on en parle mais il s'agit plutôt de
se dire les inégalités qu'on constate
aujourd'hui qui sont accentuées par les
erreurs du passé comment est-ce qu
ensemble dans nos cités dans nos
collectivités on va réussir
avec ce que chacun peut apporter
à corriger le tir et c'est là que je
reviens vous vos talents moi c'est à
travers ces diverses cité dans
lesquelles j'ai servi dans lesquels j'ai
eu le privilège d'observer le travail
des leaders des élus c'est là que j'ai
découvert mes talents c'est là que j'ai
découvert en fait et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je reviens toujours sur ce
terme diverses cité et là vous avez
compris un chant jeux de mots je vous
parle de diversité parce que c'est un
terme que moi je ne supporte pas
uniquement quand on parle de nos divers
talents
divers rapports qu'on est en mesure
d'apporter dans notre quotidien dans
notre collectivité pour provoquer un
changement
alors moi je vous encourage très très
très fortement
à questionner l'image que vous vous
étiez fait du leadership à questionner
l'image que vous vous étiez fait de
votre collectivité parce que je sais les
cités lives et la gouvernance locale
c'est pas nécessairement ce qui a de
plus nous attrayant on n'en parle pas
souvent et pourtant je peux vous le dire
parce que je le vaux quotidien c'est là
que vous pouvez effectivement apporter
un réel changement
comment
si on revient à certains exemples est ce
que vous savez que demain ce sera vous
qui allez déterminer le cours de
l'histoire parce que vous serez dans une
position stratégique privilégié
importantes pour déterminer qui seront
les leaders qui vont mettre en place des
politiques des directives des lois des
politiques publiques qui vont déterminer
les environnements dans lesquels vous
allez évoluer
c'est pas moi qu'il invente la ccit un
fait c'est un fait parce que quand vous
allez aux urnes pour voter par exemple
parce que c'est comme ça qu'un peuple
parle dans une démocratie pas je sors
tic toc
quand vous allez vous manifester
pour décider de ses choix est-ce que
vous allez choisir l'indifférence parce
que au final c'est du pareil au même
est-ce que vous allez choisir le cynisme
bien ce que vous allez saisir cette
opportunité en tant que génération z en
riant disons que si vous qui allez faire
pencher la balance on est dans un moment
décisif de l'histoire où on va soit
progresser ou régresser
parce que les choix que vous allez faire
en termes je les dis de 35 aux logiques
de mobilité de transport ecce terra si
vous choisissez selon la vision du
demain que vous voulez si vous
choisissez aujourd'hui c'est ma
génération qui va commencer à mettre les
bases de ces changements là si vous
optez pour l'indifférence
malheureusement je pense que ce qui nous
attend
sera peut-être tragique
sera peut-être âgées parce que qu'on
pense à certains défis d'importance dans
lesquels je le sais que vous avez du
talent je le vois parce que je le
perçois dont vous y je sais que il y en
a parmi vous par exemple qui ont des
talents dans l'art dans la culture qui
ont les compétences une aisance
naturelle pour créer des événements
payer des des moments mobilisateur qui
rassemble les gens des moments qui
permettent non seulement de bâtir des
ponts mais de briser les d isolement il
est solitude je le vois parce que
certains d'entre vous avaient choisi
d'évoluer dans les technologies de
l'information et vous avez des
compétences que vous ne savez même pas
encore qui vont permettre de bâtir des
systèmes des infrastructures mini grande
moyenne peu importe mais qui viendront
par exemple résoudre des enjeux qui
passe de l'accessibilité universelle à
l'accessibilité alimentaire
donc moi je vous dirais que si j'étais
dans la poussant privilégiée dans
laquelle vous êtes stratégie que vous
pouvez faire pencher la balance
j'aurais oui pris le temps nécessaire
pour évoluer dans mes talents mais
j'aurais tellement aimé à 18 ans qu'on
me dise que le moment où je serai appelé
à exercer mon leadership viendrait
beaucoup plus tôt que je leur anticipées
si j'avais su ça
j'aurais d'eternit définitivement pris
beaucoup plus de plaisir à me découvrir
à travers ma place dans ma collectivité
dans ses diversités où j'ai été j'aurais
définitivement pris beaucoup plus de
plaisir à me découvrir à travers les
autres à travers les solutions que je
pouvais a mené par mes talents naturels
en fait parce que mes talents naturels
était ce qu'il y avait de plus aisé de
plus commode de plus confortable hills à
travers ses talents naturels là que
j'aurais pu être propulsé vers librement
beaucoup plus inconfortable comme par
exemple combien ils sont en stage devant
des gens qu'on connaît pas qui nous
regarde puis qui nous jugent peut-être
jeudi max et vous
mais ces moments inconfortable a qui
sont nécessaires pour wii nous propulser
mais surtout pour engager des
changements parce que c'est dans ces
moments là qu'on peut connecter
donc je vous laisse avec une réflexion
refaites le monde oui reflète le fait
pas peur
mais refaire le monde avec votre monde
et commencer par votre monde
c'était diversité là que je voulais vous
parler
[Applaudissements]